[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: We're driving to
Green Bank, West Virginia,
and the radio just went out,
I lost cellphone service,
no Wi-Fi.
And that's because we just
entered the National Radio
Quiet Zone.
It's been called the
quietest place in America.
There are no cellphone towers,
Wi-Fi is highly restricted,
microwaves too.
The US National Radio Quiet
Zone, a 13,000 square mile area
was established in 1958
to protect telescopes
like these from
electromagnetic frequencies
that could cause
harmful interference.
We went 450 feet
up to the very top
of the world's largest
steerable radio telescope
in Green Bank, West Virginia.
In being up here, I feel
like a speck on the earth.
JAY LOCKMAN: What
it's used for really
makes me feel like a
speck on the earth,
because it's used by
scientists to study
things that are going on
very far out in the universe.
Stars that are being formed,
or stars that are dying,
galaxies and their collisions.
People have looked for
life using this telescope.
LAURA LING: What makes this
particular telescope unique?
JAY LOCKMAN: What makes it
unique is, for one thing,
it's location.
It's in the National
Radio Quiet Zone,
and so we're free from a lot of
the man-made interference that
would really block study
of sensitive signals.
The tiniest little
transmitter, even
things like cellphones or
even the kind of transmitters
that are in your digital camera
would wipe out the signals.
Another thing is its sheer size.
It's a very good, very
precise tracking instrument,
so a lot of things
put together make
it an absolute unique
instrument for the study
of a large range of phenomena
out there in the universe.
LAURA LING: Do some
people feel as if they're
living in a little bubble here?
JAY LOCKMAN: In a
sense, I feel like I'm
living in the little
wonderland, because we have
this great science
going on here,
and I suppose there
are people that
can't imagine doing
without cellular service,
but for most of human history
we managed quite well.
Think of it as living in 1980.
LAURA LING: I love the '80s.
JAY LOCKMAN: Well, the fashion
left something to be desired.
LAURA LING: Jonah Bauserman
patrols the 10-mile radius
around the National Radio
Astronomy Observatory
to make sure there are no
electromagnetic frequencies
that might interfere
with the telescopes.
JONAH BAUSERMAN: This is
actually NRAO property,
you know, the folks that live
here sign a rental agreement,
and it basically
says you are not
allowed to have microwave ovens,
Wi-Fi, cordless telephones.
Anything that could transmit a
signal is strictly forbidden.
LAURA LING: So no Lean Cuisines
for these guys for dinner?
JONAH BAUSERMAN: Nope Or
they have to figure out
another alternative to cook it.
LAURA LING: I mean, it
does seem in some ways
that this town is kind
of from a different era.
JONAH BAUSERMAN: It
is a unique area.
We're kind of locked back
in time, if you will.
LAURA LING: The National
Radio Quiet Zone is not only
a place of scientific
research and discovery,
it's become a haven
of sorts for people
who believe they suffer
from a condition known
as electromagnetic
hypersensitivity,
that electromagnetic
fields make them sick.
DIANE SCHOU: I got
a headache that
was like a sledgehammer
on the head.
JENNIFER WOOD: I started
losing weight really fast.
I got emaciated.
The doctors were
really frightened.
They thought maybe I had cancer.
MELISSA CHALMERS: I
was very nauseous.
I was throwing up all the time.
Every moment of every
day was absolute torture.
LAURA LING: Diane
Schou, Jennifer Wood,
and Melissa Chalmers are
among the few dozen people who
have moved to Green Bank
in the last few years
to try to escape the
ever-growing reach
of Wi-Fi technology.
What sorts of things
were making you sick?
DIANE SCHOU: Well,
originally it was just
the cellphone tower
that was near my home,
but after that it
became cellphones,
and eventually it also
morphed into power lines,
electrical devices, fluorescent
lights are horrible.
The electricity
became so painful
that when the neighbor
ran her coffee maker,
I was in such pain,
with such a headache
and, oh, that really hurt.
MELISSA CHALMERS: When
I was using the phone,
after couple minutes, I
would start getting numb
on this side of my face,
and so I would turn it off,
but then the last
time I used it,
my face went numb for two weeks.
JENNIFER WOOD: A lot of
houses I can't even be in,
so this is why I hand-built my
own house with no electricity.
LAURA LING: There
are some people
who say that what
you're suffering
from is not a condition, it's an
affliction, it's in your head.
How does that make you feel?
DIANE SCHOU: They're uneducated.
They are closed minded,
and they are selfish.
It is real.
It is true.
LAURA LING: How
did you feel when
you arrived in this quiet zone?
MELISSA CHALMERS: I
felt great, actually.
You know, at one point, my
whole body just relaxed.
DIANE SCHOU: By getting
away, I was able to recover.
I do have electricity
in my home.
I use it carefully.
So therefore, I do
have a computer.
I can go to local grocery
store, I can go to church.
I can be with people,
and they're not carrying
a cell phone in their pocket.
JENNIFER WOOD: As
soon as I moved in,
I was completely out of all
electrical fields and all cell
phone reception.
Within two weeks, I noticed
I was already gaining weight.
MELISSA CHALMERS: It
took a couple days
for the ringing in my ears to
stop here, and after two days
I never wanted to leave.
There no other place
like it that I've seen.
LAURA LING: But as technology
continues to creep in,
things may be getting a little
louder in the quiet zone.
JONAH BAUSERMAN: We've got
quite a few Wi-Fi modems here
in the area.
These could potentially
cause harmful radio frequency
interference to the telescope.
I would say there's probably
maybe 40, maybe 50 Wi-Fi modems
just driving through
the town of Green Bank.
LAURA LING: Wow, that's a lot
of Wi-Fi for the town that's
not supposed to have any Wi-Fi.
JONAH BAUSERMAN: It's a
little bit disheartening,
but it is what it is, I suppose.
LAURA LING: Even though
they're not supposed to,
people here are accessing things
such as wireless technology,
and so you have to wonder,
how long can this place truly
remain a quiet zone?
MELISSA CHALMERS: I
think eventually the zone
will be threatened.
People are going to want
to use the technology,
because they want to use it.
I don't know what I'll do.
JONAH BAUSERMAN: The type of
science that we're doing here
is not just for right
here, right now,
in this day and time.
It's for the next generation.
The universe is vast, it's
huge, it's magnificent,
and to be able to
take a tool like this
and look back through time
is just astounding to me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Be sure to watch
one of these other episodes.
Click the top video for
a look into the science
behind fecal transplants
and how it's saving lives.
Or click the bottom video to
see how a Hollywood stunt man
mentally prepares
to get lit on fire.
Thanks for watching,
and please subscribe.